we're here in London and we're going to
find out can people play for one minute
straight
can survive they get 100 let's do it
we've set up the room full of cheeky
little distractions so let's hope
they're good enough when we say so
the timer will go on and you have 60
seconds there might be some surprises
Ready Set Go
60 Seconds
but they look quite solid maybe if we
dim the lights down a bit oh no
yeah six the seconds in the clock
starting three two one go
you went for your best serve yeah I
don't care about the six chicken as long
as I beat him up as soon as I turn right
he's gonna put me in a retirement home
right Dad get out
no no we're not against each other we're
trying to help each other so just just
like a nice just up and down three two
one go
[Music]
so we hit them with the lights
[Music]
yeah you can do it let's hit them with
the lights
[Laughter]
and turn lights off I'm scared go
good
five seconds in nice keep it going keep
it going keep it going
you still got it
oh that's a day yeah
yeah so all you got to do is keep the
ball in play for 60 seconds okay and if
you can do it you get 100 pounds nice
breakfast put them in space yes well
it's going well don't mind us we'll just
have a game of our own here
hope we're not disturbing you too much
no oh so this doesn't affect them at all
often we've got to think of something
[Music]
no one has completed the 60 Second
Challenge yet maybe our presence is just
so intimidating that people get
these are okay very nice it's our own
rackets oh okay these are nice bro go
talking about our Sensei racket we have
a campaign on our web store where if you
buy one of these you'll also get a
racket case signed by all three of us
let's see if the Sensei racket helps
these guys win the main prize don't pay
attention to him he's not even there six
five four three two one go
come on thanks for getting the money bro
yeah you should play one point winner
get some money yeah one point
one point one point when you get some
money
sudden death
[Applause]
so anyway give me that money you're
subscribe to Infinity right I am
subscribed that's why I clocked you
straight away that is good and I didn't
want to say there's no way he's in Old
Street balance go and hit subscribe
you won't regret it am I right oh
definitely not go
[Music]
oh my God
we've been done by the course inside a
wet floor sign I can't believe it and
along the video we'll be having
different distractions so make sure you
watch until the end foreign
[Music]
you can do it
oh
it was the pressure go
[Music]
they're going high temper that's a
that's a new tactic
nice and easy but it's looking really
solid oh they hit the racket oh but you
can go oh to never last more than a
minute as it is
I'm calm Ready Set go
seconds keep it home
already makes it two two one distraction
ball
[Music]
the one distraction ball this time
no no no don't worry
and on the count of three the time
you're looking really nervous yeah
yes sir do you want a glass of water or
anything go
started for a 54.
we'll give them that we can
do when it's gone
keep it going 35.
come on just keep it going
halfway shut up
we'll still win the money yeah
three two one
oh no no but we just won two one no we
didn't win previously that was a good
yeah surprise okay let us know in the
comments do you think they managed the
rally I hope
we've been practicing
that was meant oh we're gonna make it
challenging don't worry
60 seconds started
because it's not the amount of shots
it's just the amount of time let's give
them some
other balls
oh
you're 30 seconds in
[Music]
anniversary six five four three two
let's go foreign
[Applause]
thank you very much
yeah thumbs up guys I know your channel
really yeah yeah I've seen you guys
we've got this okay guys good easy money
go 60 seconds has started
slow it down let's slow it down a bit
there we go some intense music looking
good guys
be better I know you're about to mess
with us
for a minute already come on you can do
it easy come on 15 seconds left
foreign
[Music]
the next distraction dinosaur attack wow
it might be some slight distraction no
beef here no drama are we ready no Ready
set go 60 seconds has started
[Music]
they're going strong
they're unfazed by the dinosaur
oh my God 25 seconds left
this got me though this was more scary
than a dinosaur yeah do you know what I
should have come back with my sister
because we've all played competitively
we could do that I love your faith in me
here yeah
table tennis Gods I forsake the mini
golf gods
[Music]
I can't believe how quickly six seconds
that's not good I don't have any
expectations
wow how long do we have for this 60.
it's never gonna happen how long do we
have well you have one try but it's not
gonna happen I'm never gonna do this can
I get someone else to communicate let's
find someone else yeah yeah
one two three now you definitely have it
oh no three don't mess up the serve one
go
they're also fast tempo this is what I'm
looking strong that's his pair as well
30 seconds nice and chilled the
pressure's on
and they do it you can do it don't hit
it too far pressure
it was the lifestyle help guys just hang
five
four
seconds oh God are you joking
don't worry about the pendulum never hit
okay okay we're gonna have to check the
replay because that was on the second oh
my god when did the ball hit the ground
okay
that's a good point if it hits the
ground hold him and hit the ground
before yes
make sure you hit subscribe and see you
next time and huge thanks to bounce old
Street for letting us use their amazing
venue